hey youtubers it's Charlie so hopefully
you guys have seen some of the big news
coming out of d23 I just did a Captain
America Civil War video this morning but
they also brought a bunch of Doctor
Strange stuff so there's gonna be a
breakdown of what they said and what
they showed off there's still deep in
production on the movie right now
Benedict Cumberbatch himself though has
moved on to Hamlet I think he's doing
that play in London but they shot Doctor
Strange is the same place where they
shoot a lot of other big Disney movies
like the Star Wars stuff so here we go
Doctor Strange first they showed him
going to the Far East then being
transported to multiple dimensions
remember they kind of teased that with
ant-man although technically ant-man
wasn't flying into a different dimension
they called that the quantum realm but
Kevin Feige was just teasing that people
like Doctor Strange would be able to
pass between realms the same way ant-man
was passing between realms although the
science behind it is very different just
think of it in terms of different
microcosms like you know you find an
Asgard on a different plane of existence
but the place they went their cards
flying through the air in the city then
we saw an image of Baron Mordo fighting
him Baron Mordo being played by chiwetel
ejiofor then him with a full-on red cape
straight out of the comics and no they
didn't say that they were gonna be
releasing any of this footage they're
like we're definitely not gonna be
releasing this till later in the year
even though there was Captain America
footage on like a a leaked cellphone
that I saw earlier today so we'll see if
it leaks but it's just the earliest of
stuff it's like when they had Star Wars
Celebration
and they were showing off stuff from the
spin-off movies even though they were
really there to promote episode 7
speaking of which they did have some
Star Wars stuff to show off but I'll
talk about that in a different video
they were talking about rogue one
but the reason everyone flipped out when
they were showing this stuff off even
though it's very preliminary is because
Benedict Cumberbatch was doing
full-blown magic pulling big physical
magical chains and the look was spot-on
he definitely looks like Doctor Strange
now I know in Secret Wars right now he
has like a certain look to him like they
tweak it just a little bit from run to
run but Benedict Cumberbatch will be
Doctor Strange like you you won't even
think about it when you see him on
screen there'll be a lot of Sherlock
jokes flying around for sure you know
especially because Martin Freeman is now
part of the Marvel movies too but once
you see footage of him you'll know
exactly why they cast him he's like one
of the best character actors in the
world right now and one of the best
leading men but you
remember that this is a very different
type of movie than a traditional
Avengers film or even Captain America
Civil War which is kind of an Avengers
film by itself anyway if ant-man is that
you know the quote-unquote small quirky
version of a Marvel film Doctor Strange
is gonna be like the crazy acid trip of
a Marvel film heavy mysticism spells the
demon plane you'll also see some of the
ideas about traveling between planes
that we saw in the Thor movies they
haven't explained this 2l in the movies
but but in the comics the Asgardians use
the Rainbow Bridge to travel between
realms and you can't travel to Asgard if
you have a spaceship like the guardians
of the galaxy couldn't just fly to
Asgard you can only get there via the
Rainbow Bridge or if you have another
entrance in like Loki like a back door
because it's on a different plane of
existence now it gets really confusing
after that because the Asgardians have
an afterlife but we can talk about that
when I do my next Thor Ragnarok video
which actually shouldn't be too long
because they'll probably be talking a
little bit more about that soon too but
in terms of actual footage of Doctor
Strange right now all they have is like
a visual effects demo that they showed
off so it's a lot of concept art a lot
of visual effects like the stuff that
they don't necessarily need the actors
for the stuff with the actors that they
shoot takes a lot more time to edit and
process whenever they're trying to get
big actors like Benedict Cumberbatch to
sign their contracts they show them
concept art when they're telling them
about the movie and about the character
they want them to play so they prepare a
lot of this in advance you would be
amazed at how much of these Marvel films
get made without actual actors being
cast in certain roles seriously it is a
machine like they crank these movies out
but if you've never watched any of Scott
Derrickson stuff he's the person that's
directing the film watch deliver us from
evil and you'll see why they may have
chose him for this film he just has a
really interesting take on this
supernatural horror type story really
trippy really scary really mystical so
aside from the stuff they showed off at
d23 there isn't a whole lot that we've
seen from the Doctor Strange movie like
they just started making it recently but
Benedict Cumberbatch was at a Film
Festival earlier this year talking about
the character people were talking to him
about going to China learning about
meditating he actually said he does that
a lot in real life just to get away from
the circus that has become his life
since he's been so popular so he's
actually a pretty deeply spiritual
person I know that'll make the more
intense fans that much more nuts about
him just learning that he's really deep
in real life you get the vibe that he's
one of the more interesting actors that
you could ever have a conversation with
you know like hanging out with Robert
Downey jr. probably like hanging out
with a 15 year old kid you know lots of
fun get into some trouble together and
Cumberbatch did say that he actually
reads comics right now typically when
most actors are being eyed for roles
Marvel will send them like a dumptruck
of comics no case you guys didn't know
just a quick reminder Doctor Strange is
the second Marvel movie next year
there's still only two Marvel movies the
year after that in 2017 they'll be 3 and
then Doctor Strange is currently
scheduled for November 4th that date
could change us a little bit but I'm
expecting it to still be in November the
last Marvel movie that I remember seeing
around that time of year was actually
the last Thor film I think Thor Ragnarok
is also gonna be around that time of
year and just for reference here's that
Disney schedule they showed on screen
once again these are all of Disney's IP
though so that includes the Pixar stuff
the Marvel stuff the Star Wars stuff all
the way through 2017 this is just the
next couple of years we're starting to
enter the shut up and take my money zone
speaking of which Disney is making shut
up and take my money land also known as
Star Wars land they're actually calling
it Star Wars land I'll talk about that a
little bit in my Star Wars video but
it's basically like an Independent Star
Wars theme park it's gonna be associated
with Disneyland in Disney World but
there'll be one in Anaheim and there'll
be one in Orlando if you live in an
international country and you love to
come to Disneyland
on vacation don't worry though it's
gonna be 2017 before they break ground
on it so you probably won't be able to
visit it as a theme park till 2018
so what I'm gonna do next is I'm gonna
do a Star Wars video for all the Star
Wars stuff that they showed off they
talked about rogue one they showed off
some new stuff for Episode seven there
wasn't a new trailer but they did show
off a lot of new stuff couple big bombs
being dropped Finn is now confirmed Jedi
speaking of Awesome couple giveaway
winners to announce so congratulations
to Chelsea Ward
kamar Michael schepis and Annie Sanders
you guys all win $20 Amazon gift cards
just message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact info
I'll be sure to remind everyone when I
post my Star Wars video that'll probably
be tomorrow morning like I probably
won't finish that till tomorrow morning
so while you guys wait for that you can
click here to learn all about the
Captain America Civil
footage that they actually showed off
and you can click here to learn all
about the new characters coming to the
flash season 2 in arrow season 4 maybe
some Green Lantern stuff thank you so
much watching everybody has been really
awesome day so let's high five I'll see
you guys tomorrow
you